i
[Música]
la pandemia de kobe 19 deja ya a más de
2 millones de muertos en todo el mundo
esto mientras algunos países luchan por
acelerar sus procesos de vacunación y
otros ni siquiera tienen acceso a los
fármacos que prevendría en las
instrucciones la oms se advierte que no
se está logrando romper las cadenas de
transmisión
por cuarto día consecutivo brasil
reportó más de mil muertes en 24 horas
esto en medio del colapso sanitario
manaos la mayor ciudad de la amazonía
que debido al aumento de casos ve como
escasean las camas y los suministros de
oxígeno para los pacientes el presidente
ya ir bolsonaro dice que el gobierno ya
ha hecho su parte para ayudar
el presidente electo de estados unidos
joe biden invocará la ley de producción
de defensa con el fin de acelerar los
esfuerzos de vacunación en su país
kobe 19 será sólo uno de los múltiples
retos del próximo mandatario que también
enfrenta una posible ola de actos
violentos de cara a su juramentación el
20 de enero washington dice se encuentra
militarizada ante una posible nueva
movilización de simpatizantes de dos en
otro
[Música]
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france24 blanco un gusto
saludarlos comenzamos a este informativo
hablando de la pandemia de coke 19
porque el mundo ya superó los 2 millones
de fallecidos a causa de la enfermedad
veamos ahora cómo está el panorama
global según los datos de la universidad
johns hopkins el total de casos
registrados superan los 96 millones 600
mil el número de fallecidos alcanzan los
dos millones tres mil personas y el
total de recuperados se sitúa alrededor
de 51 millones 579 mil entretanto el
jefe del comité de emergencia de la
organización mundial de la salud afirmó
que el mundo está en una nueva carrera
con un coronavirus que intenta mutar y
las nuevas variantes necesitan una
investigación rápida y profunda el
director general de la organización
pedro shannon dijo que el mundo no está
logrando romper las cadenas de
transmisión del coronavirus oa nivel
comunitario y también familiar
sankán christine europe algunos países
de europa áfrica y las américas están
viendo aumentos en los casos con
múltiples factores impulsando los
riesgos de transmisión de cesvi cost con
esto es porque colectivamente no estamos
teniendo éxito en romper las cadenas de
transmisión a nivel comunitario o dentro
de los propios hogares we need to close
tenemos que cerrar la brecha entre la
intención y la implementación a nivel
local y nacional porque actualmente
existe una enorme presión sobre los
hospitales y los trabajadores de la
salud
vamos ahora hasta brasil donde la nueva
variante del cómic 19 detectada en la
amazonía brasileña tiene al sistema
hospitalario de esa región colapsado
además el país superó por cuarto día
consecutivo los mil muertos por la
enfermedad líderes y partidos de la
oposición así como organizaciones
civiles responsabilizan al presidente ya
ir bolsonaro del colapso sanitario que
sufre la mayor ciudad de la amazonía que
se quedó sin camas e sin oxígeno para
los pacientes con coronavirus el
mandatario por su parte ha dicho que el
gobierno ya ha hecho su parte
siempre estamos haciendo lo que tenemos
que hacer el problema en manaos es
terrible pero nosotros hemos hecho de
nuestra parte ofreciendo recursos
hoy las puestas armadas ha lanzado un
hospital del campo ya
administración estuve en el lugar el
lunes y entregó oxígeno y oxígeno
colombia superó este viernes por primera
vez los 20 mil contagios diarios por
coronavirus con un récord de 21 mil 21
mil 78 casos para un total de un millón
870 mil 179 infecciones confirmadas
según informó el ministerio de salud el
país también sumó 377 fallecimientos la
quinta cifra más alta desde que comenzó
la pandemia para un total de 47 mil 868
muertes por kobe 19 bogotá la capital
registra la mayor concentración de
contagios y fallecimientos ellas se
empiezan a reportar la saturación en las
camas de cuidados intensivos en varios
hospitales y clínicas de la ciudad
reino unido- refuerza sus fronteras para
hacer frente a la posible llegada de
nuevas variantes de kobe 19 a su
territorio aunque el país se ha visto
gravemente afectado por una variante
propia ahora el ministro boris johnson
anunció el cierre a partir del lunes de
todos los llamados corredores turísticos
acuerdos que implicaban que quienes
llegaran de ciertos países no tenían que
someterse a los pedidos de alistamiento
a partir de ahora todo viajero que llega
al país deberá presentar un resultado
negativo reciente y permanecer aislado
durante 10 días reino unido ya había
suspendido la llegada de vuelos desde
sudamérica y portugal por temor a la
variante brasileña
y es precisamente porque tenemos
esperanza que la vacuna y por el riesgo
de la nueva variante es que tenemos que
tomar pasos adicionales para impedir que
esas variantes entren al país
así que ayer anunciamos la prohibición
de vuelos desde suramérica y portugal
para protegernos contra los riesgos de
variantes aún no identificadas
también cerraremos temporalmente los
corredores de viaje a partir de las 4 de
la mañana del lunes a welles allman en
francia el movimiento anti vacunas ha
estado bajo fuego en las últimas semanas
en medio del temor de que la mayoría
haya aceptado su mensaje y tenga el
potencial de estropear la campaña
nacional de vacunación pero las
encuestas recientes muestran que los
franceses cada vez más están a favor de
aplicarse la dosis el primer ministro
jan castex y la bienvenida a esta
noticia el día jueves
estarían cambiando los franceses su
postura sobre ser vacunados en medio de
afirmaciones de un fuerte sentimiento
anti vacunas muchos dicen que de hecho
se están inclinando hacia ponerse la
inyección si lo pienso y lo pienso esto
es tan serio tengo que ponerme la edad y
seguir el consejo de mi sobrino que es
doctor y de mi médico de cabecera ellos
me dicen que sí que debería ponerme la
vacuna si ser de starbucks y me según
las encuestas recientes las actitudes
están cambiando a favor de la campaña
pro vacunación luego de dos meses en los
cuales el movimiento anti vacunas
parecía dominar la discusión en francia
47 por ciento de los franceses ahora
dicen que planean aplicarse la vacuna
contra un 40 por ciento que dice que
prefieren no hacerlo
preocupaciones sobre la propagación del
virus y las nuevas variantes así como el
miedo de que se imponga a otro
confinamiento podrían estar tras esa
tendencia así como el deseo de volver a
una relativa normalidad
tengo muchos amigos a los que no he
podido ver hago ejercicio en casa por mi
cuenta no es genial es negocio dos bares
en parís necesito trabajar
financieramente esto es catastrófico
todos necesitan aplicarse la vacuna no
satisfaction este doctor dice que ha
visto un cambio real en tan sólo diez
días los franceses inicialmente tenían
preocupaciones sobre la vacuna pero
desde que han visto las campañas
alrededor del mundo eeuu ha vacunado a
dos millones de personas reino unido a
un millón por ejemplo no ha habido
ningún efecto secundario grande así que
ahora están tranquilos hay una demanda
realizó un juego de hoy
ahora los mayores de 75 años pueden
pedir una cita para ser vacunados en los
próximos días y semanas y en eeuu el
presidente electo joe biden se
comprometió a incrementar las medidas
contra el cubit 19 el demócrata dijo que
maximizará el suministro disponible de
vacunas y materiales necesarios para
administrarlas utilizando una ley de la
era de la guerra fría llamada ley de
producción de defensa para dirigir la
fabricación privada esto en medio de
advertencias del fbi sobre la seguridad
del 20 de enero día de la juramentación
debaten como el presidente número 46 de
la nación por esta razón se han
extremado las medidas de seguridad en la
capital estadounidense con más de 30 mil
efectivos de las fuerzas de seguridad
del estado es por esto que quiero
saludar en este momento a patricio
zamorano analista político internacional
y codirector del consejo de asuntos
hemisféricos de washington 16 años
zamorano gracias por su tiempo y por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 me
preguntó qué tan preparadas están las
fuerzas de seguridad para hacer frente a
una posible ola de actos
de cara a la posición de júpiter es un
tema extremadamente real te quiero decir
que personalmente puedo ver directamente
aquí en la ciudad de washington dc la
militarización que está sufriendo el
distrito de columbia y empezó justamente
ayer cinco días antes de la toma de
mando se está calculando que van a
llegar más de 20.000 miembros de la
guardia nacional de los eeuu ya se están
cerrando muchas calles ya se están
prohibiendo el estacionamiento en muchas
zonas así que la verdad es que la ciudad
se lo está tomando en serio puesto que
hay pistas reales concretas de que hay
grupos de ultraderecha que se quieren
expresar de una manera violenta están
pensando en el tema armado se está
pensando también en atacar a los
congresos de los estados de cada uno de
los estados de acá de los eeuu así que
es una amenaza totalmente real no
ahora bailén dice sentirse confiado en
su seguridad durante esta juramentación
el día 20 pero está realmente a salvo el
nuevo presidente estarán seguros
asistentes a este evento
es un tema muy delicado se le está
pidiendo ayuda ya se ha filtrado que las
agencias de seguridad les están pidiendo
que se haga el juramento o el
nombramiento cerrado mucho más
controlado o en privado y yo badén se
está negando a ese tipo de realidad
porque quiere expresar un poco la
tranquilidad que él trae a la
presidencia del país pero conociendo en
el evento es un evento en una zona muy
muy abierta y hay que confiar entonces
en la autoridad de seguridad que van a
tomar las medidas para evitar que haya
cualquier tipo de problemas hay que
recordar que los eeuu hay muchas armas
en manos privadas entre los atacantes e
invasores al congreso había gente con
bombas caseras con bombas molotov y con
explosivos así que ese es un tema que
complica mucho para la seguridad es un
riesgo sin duda el que está tomando yo
vaya desde el próximo 20 de enero
patricio brevemente se conocen cada vez
más detalles sobre los actos de
violencia registrados en el capitolio el
6 de enero cree que las penas anunciadas
para los responsables y los llamados a
la calma del propio donald trump puedan
disuadir a los manifestantes
yo te diré que el voto duro en el voto
duro de donald trump y aquellos que se
consideran milicianos y tienen
sentimientos contra el estado contra los
gobiernos en general al contrario están
mucho más radicalizados frente a esta
persecución policial la mujer que fue
muerta por policía dentro del capitolio
se está convirtiendo en una mártir y
está atrayendo mucha atención de estos
grupos extremos así que yo te diría que
es una mezcla para el voto menos
comprometido los arrestos y las condenas
van a ser uno de una disuasión pero para
aquellos más radicales todos al
contrario y yo creo que se están
radicalizando incluso más por eso es que
se explican los más de 20.000 tropas que
van a estar cuidando la seguridad en el
distrito de columbia
patricio zambrano gracias por estar aquí
con nosotros en france 24 buena noche
miles de migrantes que partieron de
honduras avanzan por la frontera con
guatemala con la intención de llegar a
eeuu pese a las advertencias de los
gobiernos de ese país guatemala y méxico
de que no permitirán el ingreso de
personas que intentan cruzar de manera
irregular la nueva caravana se suma a la
que partió
en la noche del miércoles pasado de esta
misma ciudad en el grupo se encuentran
hombres mujeres y menores de edad el
gobierno de guatemala autorizó el uso de
la fuerza y exige además pruebas del
cobach 19 a sus integrantes
el recuento de los votos está en marcha
en uganda tras las elecciones
presidenciales del día jueves pero la
comisión electoral del país es ya fijo
ya dijo este viernes el actual
presidente yoweri museveni lleva una
amplia delantera en la carrera electoral
veamos el informe
después de que asegurara que las
elecciones del jueves fueron
fraudulentas el candidato de la
oposición bob higuain dijo que estaba
bajo arresto domiciliario y que su vida
corría peligro acusó a las fuerzas de
seguridad de entrar ilegalmente en su
propiedad
cuando les pregunto qué están haciendo
dentro de mi propiedad porque están
traspasando ellos me dicen que le
pregunta el portavoz militar del hecho
no sé qué tiene en mi vida como objetivo
sé que están intentando normalizar sus
acciones para que cuando me hagan algo
terrible esté normalizado
actions un portavoz militar dijo a los
periodistas que las fuerzas de seguridad
estaban allí para protegerlo la comisión
electoral dijo que su oponente el actual
presidente llevaba la delantera en el
conteo de votos
museveni que ha estado en el poder por
35 años y está postulando para un sexto
mandato prometió aceptar los resultados
por supuesto si los resultados son
legítimos porque no debería aceptarlos
porque felicitó a los que votaron dejada
al país ser pacífico nadie debería
intentar traer violencia las autoridades
dijeron que la votación se desarrolló
con pocos incidentes pero el personal de
seguridad y su fuerte presencia y las
redes sociales fueron cortadas en la
capital kampala los residentes dicen que
el miedo ha mantenido a la gente lejos
de las calles
creo que nada va a pasar porque la gente
está asustada por supuesto no se pueden
manifestar o hacer nada malo la
violencia irrumpió durante la campaña
con varios arrestos y el asesinato de 12
manifestantes muchos dejaron la capital
temiendo por su seguridad los resultados
finales se esperan para el sábado
y de esta manera entonces llegamos al
final del informativo en france 24
continúan con nosotros son muy buenas
noches para todos
[Música]
en un instante economía